Trust me on this, when people try and rush you through the process, don't let them.
They want to jump on a Zoom call.
I can't remember who dropped the one-liner, it was beautiful.
But say something like this, hey, that's cool, I want to talk with you on Zoom as well and
talk about this.
But honestly, I only work with one company.
So before we get too ahead of ourselves, I want to see how you actually handle these
leads before we, you know, I waste my time or you waste your time.
It's a two-way street here.
I'm not, you know, I'm not looking for everybody, okay?
So they want to start pushing you, pull back, pull back.
It's going to make them want you more.
You're going to become the pretty girl in the club that everybody wants to touch, everybody
wants to dance with and ain't nobody got business touching and they're not going to, okay?
That's who you're going to become by pulling back.
So follow the process.